what's like the riskiest thing you've
ever watched in the flight
uh what do you mean risky i don't know i
saw a guy playing watching porn one time
i thought that was impressive i remember
the first time i like watched prison
school on a flight
that was that was that was like [ __ ] did
you do that i was just like okay i
really want to watch prison school i
downloaded it should probably explain
how bad prison schools okay
prison school is like before there was
interspecies reviewers basically there
was like prison schools
it's one step away from hentai yeah i
feel like how far
you could push echi i mean there's
there's a scene where
like i think the girl a girl pisses on a
guy accidentally yeah you know
as you do as you do as you do it's it's
[ __ ] i hate it when that happens yeah
it's hilarious though it's hilarious
it's like one of the funniest edgy anime
that i have seen
like but it's it was like a few years
ago wasn't it how old was it when it
came out
17 2018 yeah because i was a big fan of
the manga it was one of the few manga
that
literally had me like crying laughing
yeah when i was reading it so i was like
i gotta watch this when it was out but
it has a very unfortunate ending
yeah yeah i have i haven't actually read
through the ending yeah
it's a bit unfortunate yeah yeah because
i was the same i read the manga and i
thought this was one of the funniest
things i've ever read yeah
and then just oh man i don't want to say
too much about the ending but
it's it's not that great so what the
hell though did you watch that on a
plane
okay so because i felt ashamed watching
it wait wait
hold on where were you sitting okay i
was sitting on the end right and i had
an ipad
okay wait the whole everyone who walks
gets to see it i mean i don't care about
them right i care about the people
saying nice to meet you right now why
why do you not care about them
sitting next to me was like a little kid
you're like you're gonna love this so
so at the beginning right i was like
okay i was trying to be discreet about
it
right i was like because i was like it
was on an ipad so i was trying to watch
it as close to my face as possible you
know you know and i'm like trying to be
discreet so like
putting blinders on this thing exactly
and then
it was like a 10 hour flight so my arms
are gonna get tired yeah and then
about like an hour and i was like i
don't [ __ ] give a [ __ ] anymore
and you know if the kid wants to look
over you know that there's there's some
culture in his life
you want to be a chad kid watch this um
because it wasn't the only thing i
watched as well i watched um because the
new season of game of thrones as well so
i thought
i saw you know you know what i've
already watched prison school
i mean they can't blame me that time
because it was on their selection right
so you know um i'm sorry kid or you're
that you're you're welcome kid
he's a massive
do you get to the point on a long ass
flight it's like a flight that's over
like eight hours right
where you have one hour left and you
need to pick something to watch
and that one hour of content is like the
worst watching
oh i don't even bother with that kind of
stuff yeah if if there's
less than two hours remaining on a
flight i just don't even bother starting
what do you do uh i either read a book
or sleep
yeah it's it's just like that twilight
zone because it's awful
i hate it because it's the same when i
know i have to do something in an hour
and i'm like i could squeeze in an anime
episode in this time it's like yeah but
i never do
a random family guy episode yeah i guess
because i hate myself
big bang theory episode right after why
not no big bang theory is never worth it
no no no no no when i see people
watching that on the plane for like
six hours straight like what's wrong
with you what went wrong where this is
the pig
i couldn't escape from the big bang
theory thing right because of my surname
bazinga so many people were like oh look
the big bang dude you're like
shut the [ __ ] up no